when i was growing up i was talking
about this early with our staff because
you know we we
we're doing what we're doing today and i
gave a message to them about what took
place when i was growing up
i watched my mom she'd come at home
six o'clock her aunties would come over
and i was six seven years old and they
were armenian
and they would come over and they would
have the coffee and they would sit down
for two hours before my dad came home
and they would talk about how many
things my dad was doing wrong
and how she needs to tell him
your husband's not doing this he's not
doing that and i would sit there and i
would listen i'm six seven years i'm
like oh my gosh why are they saying this
stuff about my dad
and i'm acting like i'm playing in the
background but i'm listening to
every single thing right and then my mom
my dad would come home and the aunties
would be like quite quiet
okay we're gonna go home the moment the
auntie's left guess what my dad and my
mom would do they get into the biggest
fight yeah argue like crazy
terrible fights and i know what caused
the fight
and i was furious but i didn't know what
to say then i would go with my dad
and i'd be around his two brothers who
never got married and they would say
this is why we never get married you
should tell your wife what to do
your wife shouldn't be telling you this
they don't because we're in iran in iran
wife doesn't tell husband anything
while you're in iran this is while i'm
in iran and i would watch my uncles
fire my dad up and i'm in the back
playing legos and i'm listening i'm like
oh my gosh
then we'd go home and my mom and dad
would be together guess what my dad
would say
i can't believe this and you know i'm a
man and you got to tell me like oh
that was sponsored by the brothers and
then guess what happened to my parents
they got a divorce
as a kid when i was 10 years old and my
parents got a divorce if anybody's gone
through a divorce and they were at one
point together
the kid's dream is for the mom and dad
to get back together you're kind of
hoping that this happens because it's a
heartbreak
you want to go to dinner with mom and
dad you want to go experience what it is
to be our mom and dad you want dad's
footsteps coming up
from 10 years old till 21 years old
i can count how many nights i slept in
the same place as my dad
two three hundred nights i didn't see my
dad my dad i saw him once every two
weeks he would come and park behind
virgils
i was living off of doran and glendale
in glendale california he'd pick me up
we'd go there for one day sunday i'd
come back home
once every other week he would pick me
up and go to places together
the entire thing was instigated by their
families
most divorces are caused by friends and
parents most divorces are caused by
family this is why when we got married
my wife and i sat my mom down the night
before we got married
and i told my mom something i said mom
effective today
you're the number one woman in my life
effective tomorrow you are the number
two woman in my life
boom and that changes and don't even
think about getting into our family
at all and i said the same thing to my
wife's family
i said your daughter and i are going to
have many fights but it's none of your
business
wow and i said to my dad i said if i
ever come to you bitching about my wife
i need you to defend my wife
and i said to my wife if you ever go to
your parents and you about me they
have to defend me
if not we're gonna get a divorce and i
don't know about this marriage stuff
because it's very complex